[Music]
hello and welcome to spanner internals
part 2 this is a second talk we had a
talk yesterday called spanner internals
part one that was around how sort of
spanner internally works and how its
evolved as a system over time inside
Google and then we externalize it into
the cloud so today we're going to focus
on one of the critical systems built on
top of spanner internally which is
Google Cloud storage but before that
let's sort of start out with what is
cloud spanner so my name is Deepti
Shrivastav I am the product manager for
cloud spanner which is our Google cloud
platform managed database offering which
is offered on GCP and we we talk about
it as the only enterprise grade globally
distributed and strongly consistent
database service which is built
specifically for the cloud right and
what does that really mean it means that
this database service combines the
benefit of relational semantics with no
relational traditionally no sequel
horizontal scale so we have schemas we
have asset transactions we have sequel
and we have the ease of scalability and
the high availability such as four nines
of availability for original
configurations five nines of
availability for our multi region
configurations and all of this is
packaged up in a fully managed database
service that runs on Google's cloud
infrastructure so as I said the special
thing about spanner that no other
database system in the world currently
has is the ability to do acid
transactions and have strong consistency
even across when and across data centers
and across regions right no other
database in the world today
can do actual strong transaction and
strong consistency and transactions when
you start to put the replicas in more
than one data center that are actually
separated from each other through like
wider your network fibre and that that
speciality allows both our customers who
are using cloud spanner to build
interesting applications on top of it
that can be globally distributed while
having you know we have to write
semantics it also allows our internal
services to build some very exciting and
differentiated services on top of cloud
on top of the internal spanner so you
know we talk about internal span or an
external spanner but what are the real
differences here
so spanner internally or externally it's
actually the same infrastructure right
is the same binary it's running whether
it's serving external stuff or internal
stuff the only difference is the access
path so externally you know we have when
you're talking to cloud span or the
access path is through the Google cloud
platform API is and through all the
security and all those kinds of things
whereas internally we have our own
internal access paths and we keep the
data separated for obvious reasons right
we don't want to mix external customer
data with internal data so you know
obviously all of the security and
privacy and compliance aspects apply but
you know in terms of are you giving me a
slightly different version we're not for
giving you the same spanner that we have
internally for our critical services the
other differences are you know in
terminology so my colleague will come up
and talk about some of these but
basically externally we have cloud
spanner nodes which we call spanner
servers internally and externally we
have instance configurations which are
the topology for how how replication is
done basically our application topology
and this can be you know regional
configurations or multi region
configurations for those who are
familiar with spanner spanner is
inherently replicated so we have three
replicas for regional
and five seven nine replicas more
multi-region depending on which
configuration we've chosen and these
things are called sort of spanner
configurations internally so as I said
essentially it's the same differentiated
technology that we use internally and
have done for seven eight nine years
which is why we feel so confident about
you know hosting our customers on it in
the cloud because it's battle-tested
it's hardened and most of Google's
critical services at this point run on
spanner one of those critical services
are is Google Cloud storage
GCS which is a very popular service it's
built on top of spanner and because of
stress spanner is strong external
consistency as we call it GCS is able to
provide very differentiated set of
capabilities to its customers so to tell
you about that more I'd love to invite
Dennis who is our our colleague here
that is why don't you come up all right
thanks Deepti so a little bit about
myself I am a the tech lead for GCS is
metadata layer for Google Cloud Storage
and hopefully you are already somewhat
familiar with Google Cloud Storage and
we or maybe have even seen one of our
other talks but I'm gonna talk a little
bit about give you an overview of what
GCS is all about and then go into depth
in how GCS takes advantage of spanner
so GCS is object storage made simple
it's a central repository for all your
organization's
data putting it under a single
consistent unified API and so GCS is
able to store a wide variety of data
whether it be content serving data
whether it be analytics data that we're
wires high-bandwidth or even warm cold
storage or archival tears it's highly
reliable GCS provides up to four nines
of availability and multi-regional
storage it's extremely cost-effective
GCS can store hot data but it also
stores cold data offering gigabyte price
per gigabyte of as low as four cents a
gigabyte or sorry point four cents a
gigabyte and we just introduced our Ike
ival storage tier which is as low as 0.1
two cents per gigabyte GCS is secure
it's a great way of keeping your data
secure it's data is encrypted at rest
and in transit when stored in GCS and
were integrated with cloud storage
solutions like I am and kms GCS offers
three different location types there's
what's called regional storage and
that's where your data is stored
redundantly within one of our cloud
regions across availability zones within
that region and that's really good for
analytics data this regional storage is
a great way of ensuring that your data
is co-located with your compute so you
can get really high bandwidth access to
your data within that region our second
location type is what's called multi
regional storage and that's where your
data is spread redundantly across
multiple regions within a within a multi
region where being a multi region being
us asia or EU and this is really great
for content serving we have over a
hundred points of presence where this
data can be stored which means that if
you're doing content serving oftentimes
the data is located very close to where
it's being requested and so we can
minimize latency minimize bandwidth by
distributing it wide
across the multi-region and then the
third location.type is dual regional
this is something that we've introduced
recently that kind of combines the best
of both worlds
dual regional is a great way of ensuring
that your data is located in too
specific in a specific pair of regions
and this way you can ensure that you
have really high bandwidth access to
that storage within those two regions
say if you want to use that data for
analytics but you can get higher
availability with dual regional than you
can get with regional so if you need to
have an analytics application where you
need to potentially failover between
regions dual regional is a great way of
providing that and Twitter's an example
of a user that's using our dual regional
storage right now for analytics vimeos
an example of a user that's using our
multi regional storage for content
serving so GCS provides a lot of key
features these are this is an example of
four key differentiating features of GCS
and what's important to keep in mind is
that as I'm going to go into in more
detail
GCS uses spanner heavily under the hood
in its implementation and all of these
features are in some way enabled by the
fact that GCS is using spanner so let's
talk about the first one strongly
consistent listings what this means is
that when you do an object listing in
GCS you're guaranteed to see exactly
what's there not some partial view and
this makes your applications on top of
storage much simpler because you can
rely on your storage layer being
consistent
GCS offers geo redundancy within the
system so as opposed to systems where
you have to sort of cobble together geo
redundancy
at layers above the storage system by
adding replication and across regional
replication GCS offers that as part just
in one package and we of course leverage
the fact that spanners metadata is geo
redundant in order to provide this GCS
is highly scalable so much like spanner
is used internally very heavily by
Google GCS is also used really heavily
by many systems across Google and so we
are we've had to grow to Google scale
just to support Google's internal
applications and so we expose that to
our cloud users as well GCS is scalable
to exabytes and the fact that we're
using spanner as our metadata storage
within GCS really facilitates the
scalability so because we have a highly
scalable metadata layer it allows our
storage system to scale to these levels
and GCS provides a single unified
experience for all the variety of data
that you have so regardless of what
storage classes you're using or what
location types there's a single unified
API and that is also facilitated by
spanner because we're using spanner as
our centralized metadata repository it
allows us to expose for all of the data
that's in GCS it allows us to expose
this single unified metadata layer on
top API on top of that metadata so now
let's dive a little bit more deeply into
how GCS uses spanner under the hood so
you're probably familiar with the GCS
core storage abstractions and these are
buckets in objects simply an object is a
container for a collection of data like
a file in a file system and you know
objects have a particular name
there's also buckets which are
collections of objects and both of these
things have associated metadata in GCS
so there's bucket metadata and object
metadata and those that metadata is
stored in databases in spanner and GCS
is using much like Deepti alluded to GCS
is using spanner much like any other
user is using spanner it's the same
system and and so we're basically using
spanner just as as an ordinary customer
so I would say that spanner provides
four key differentiating features that
are critical for GCS is implementation
and critical for GCS is use case and the
first one is strong consistency and so
what that means for us in our
implementation is that when we do
mutations into our spanner databases
though those updates are immediately
visible to all of GCS is front-end
systems and that allows us to provide
our own user visible consistency
semantics much more simply it's
certainly possible for storage systems
to offer the kind of strong consistency
that we offer without a strongly
consistent database but that would add
tons of complexity storage systems can
do that with coherent caching layers or
fancy request routing or having master
election in the storage system but we
kind of don't have to do any of that we
don't have to deal with it we just put
our metadata in spanner and serve that
metadata out of spanner and it just kind
of takes care of the consistency issues
for us
spanner has a really simple programming
model it supports single row
transactions and we do mostly single row
transactions but we also use multi row
transactions multi table transactions
and even multi database transactions
this allows our system to be much
simpler in how it interacts with
metadata GCS is made up of many
independent components under the hood
and a lot of those components are
interacting actually directly with
metadata and so the fact that all of
these systems can interact
transactionally in a variety of
different ways with our metadata
databases it makes all of those systems
pretty simple and it gives us a lot of
confidence that our metadata is correct
and consistent the fact that spanner
supports really high availability is
critical for our use case so we use geo
redundant spanner deployments and the
fact that you only need a quorum of
zones available at any one time in order
to be serving is something that we rely
on GCS is also pretty big so the fact
that scant spanner has really excellent
horizontal scaling is very important for
our use case simply put when one of our
locations when the metadata and one of
those locations grows to the point where
we need more resources we just kind of
scale up our spanner instances and
that's a pretty simple administrative
action and spanner scalability just kind
of takes care of the fact that that
location needs to grow I'm sure that
there are scalability limits I mean
every system does have them but we just
haven't hit those limits and GCS is
already really big so just to give you
an idea some idea of what kind of scale
we're talking about when we're talking
about how big GCS is this is an example
of one of our multi regions in some
high-level data points for how big we've
been able to scale our spanner databases
in for this multi region so we're
talking about trillions of data base
rows millions of queries per second
millions of mutations per second
petabytes of logical data stored in
these database
we're using thousands of spanner servers
even for this one multi-region and there
is over a thousand miles between spanner
zones so the fact that we are have been
able to scale up our databases and a
spanner instance to this to this scale
and we haven't sacrificed our strong
consistency or high availability is
really pretty unique it's pretty cool
that we've been able to take advantage
of this so let's return to the earlier
slide where we were talking about GCS is
location types and talked about exactly
what that means in terms of our spanner
deployments for regional storage we're
using a spanner instance that is
entirely within within a region and so
just to keep in mind we use separate
spanner instances for all GCS locations
and so for regional we use a spanner
instance that's within the region and
zones that are within different
availability zones of that region for
multi regional we use a spanner instance
I'm calling them Alex in the slide
that's what we call them eternally it's
just a different name with zones that
are spread across the regions within the
multi-regional within the multi region
and for dual regional we use a spanner
instance that has zones within the two
regions of the multi region plus a third
region so now let's deep dive into
really exactly how spanner strong
consistency is so important for GCS is
use case so I've already talked about
this a little bit but I want to go into
depth into how important strong
consistency is for GCS users simply put
it's much simpler to build applications
on top of storage when the storage
system is consistent when you're getting
a complete view of what's in your
storage system at any one point in time
so you know as a specific example GCSE
offers read after right consistency
which means when you write an object
into GCSE and then later try to read it
back even if it's one of our multi
regions and you're we're doing sort of
cross region redundancies with that data
we have we provide a strong guarantee
that you read exactly what you wrote
earlier and it sounds kind of obvious
like I mean I guess you know really
every storage system should work this
way but there's a lot of storage systems
out there that don't actually provide
this guarantee that are only eventually
consistent especially when you're
talking about geo redundancy and this
makes applications a lot simpler if you
don't have this guarantee you might have
to introduce retry loops into your
application I don't know if the object
isn't there and you try and read it and
it's not then you might have to just
kind of like wait and retry later
another reason why strong consistency is
so important is that GCS is being used
by as in organisations what's called a
data Lake which means that there's many
applications that are working together
on top of storage that's centrally
located within GCS and if all of those
applications don't have a guarantee that
they're seeing exactly what's in that
shared storage system at a point in time
then it also adds more complexity to
those applications they might have to
deal with the fact that there is only a
partial view that they're seeing a
specific example of this might be like
an analytics pipeline where there's one
stage of you know a Hadoop pipeline that
is producing a data set and that data
set is later consumed by some other
stage of the pipeline which is doing
additional transformations on that data
if that later stage doesn't have a
strong guarantee that it sees everything
that was produced by that first
it's gonna be some extra you know you're
gonna have to deal with that in your
application somehow and a lot of times
it's just hard to deal with that so in
addition to strong consistency provided
by spanner being really beneficial for
our users
GCS also takes advantage of spanners
strong consistency within the
implementation of GCS so how many people
in the audience are familiar enough with
GCS to know what a compose operation is
okay not too many people so compose is a
operation that's provided by GCS and
it's a way to take a several source
objects and stitch them together into a
single destination object this is
typically used say for uploading large
objects into the system you can upload
the object in pieces and then after the
fact stitch that stitch all the pieces
together into a single object now
compose clearly is going to involve some
kind of a multi row transaction here
because it's going to be operating on
multiple objects and doing that
atomically but compose also offers
what's called preconditions which means
that for each of the source objects that
you specify you can specify that the
operation should only execute if certain
preconditions are met for instance the
objects have to match a particular
generation in order for the operation to
complete so clearly here's a case where
strong consistency is going to be really
important we're gonna want to read the
metadata for all of these objects out of
spanner and evaluate these preconditions
and then if the preconditions evaluate
commit a mutation if we don't have
strong consistency guarantees from our
database it's kind of a lot harder to
implement that that operation okay so
here's another example of how we're
taking it
spanner strong consistency so GCS has an
fsck a file system consistency checker
this is something that you know most
storage systems have it's a process
where in the background you have
something the fsck checker is something
that's running in the background and
validating that all of the metadata in
the storage system is correct that is
free of inconsistencies and a lot of
times fsck checkers want to do what's
called cross checking so validate that
the contents of one database is
consistent with on with value in another
database and in order to make these
kinds of checks simple within GCS we
take advantage of the fact that you can
take a consistent point in time snapshot
across databases and we have a strong
guarantee from spanner that everything
that's in that database even I'm sorry
in that snapshot even if it's multiple
databases is exactly what was in those
databases at that point in time so this
would make our fsck
cross-checking much simpler in this in
this example it's kind of a simple
example but this is an actual check that
we have in our fsck which is that if
there's a table of all of your objects
in a given bucket and then a separate
table in a separate database that shows
the state of the bucket whether it's
deleted or not pretty clearly if there's
objects in the bucket then the bucket
shouldn't be deleted so we want to
validate that the contents of this of
this one database as refers to this one
bucket is consistent with the
information about objects in the bucket
so here's my third example is that we're
using secondary indexes within GCS and
the way that we take advantage of
secondary indexes is to optimize the
performance of our background scanners
so sorter storage systems it's fairly
common for storage systems to have
background scanners and what these
things typically do is things like
maintenance operations so you might have
a scanner that's running over all of
your metadata periodically and doing
maintenance on the data that's that's
represented by that metadata another way
that that background scanners are used
is deferred operations so if say you do
a delete on some entity in your storage
system typically that delete is act very
quickly and it kicks off some
asynchronous work to sort of like
actually clean up the storage that's
represented by that that that object
that you're deleting and so that's sort
of a deferred action that's often driven
by a background scanner so by using
secondary indexes and in particular
sparse secondary indexes we're able to
build background scanners that are much
quicker at iterating over our metadata
because only the things that actually
need attention from the background
scanner are represented in the table
that were scanning so in this example we
have an object table and there is a
column in that object table that
represents the time at which an update
was made to that to each object and it's
only when these objects have been
updated that the background scanner
actually needs to pay attention to those
objects and so we use that update time
as the key in a secondary index and then
so that secondary index is much smaller
than the than the object table and so
the background scanner is running over
that secondary index and it's much
simpler actually to implement that
background scanner because the secondary
index is consistent with the with the
object table itself so the last thing
that I wanted to talk about is
there is it's just some of the
challenges that we've faced when when
building our system and one of the
challenges that that we do face is
something called hot spotting so what is
hot spotting the thing is that every
single system
has scaling limits that apply to
individual keys so hot spotting can
occur if you have an uneven distribution
of load within your system say for
instance you have a table of videos and
one of those videos happens to be
Gangnam style and that's represented by
one row in your table like clearly that
row is gonna be really popular and
you're gonna have to deal with some kind
of a hot spotting problem on that row
now systems can deal with this by
caching whatever is in that metadata and
distributing it more widely we choose to
not sacrifice our strong consistency
guarantees while attempting to deal with
this problem so but we have developed
some techniques to deal with it that I'm
gonna go into so you know just for some
background hot spotting strong reads in
spanner require going to the leader to
get the latest timestamp so that is
going to hot spot particular servers and
you know if you if you aren't careful
with about this in your application
design it is something that can limit
overall application performance so
there's two techniques that we employ to
minimize the issues that are created by
hot spotting and the first one is
through schema design so if the hot
spotting problem that you're facing is
that there are small ranges of keys that
can get much hotter than other ranges
say for instance in this example a
collection of objects that are all very
syn
so they share a given key prefix you can
address any potential hot spotting that
might occur on that range of your key
space by just spreading it out more
widely in your key space by applying
what we call a sharding factor so you
can basically compute a hash maybe over
the contents of your primary key and
prefix the actual primary key with that
hash it's going to have the effect of
spreading out otherwise co-located keys
much more widely and those that
spreading is going to cause these keys
to tend to fall into different spanner
splits which will improve your ability
to scale but keep in mind that this kind
of spreading can come with a cost
depending on your workload so if an
important workload for your use case is
secant is sequential scanning over your
primary key then this kind of spreading
can make that kind of sequential
scanning a little bit more expensive
because instead of scanning just one
small range of your key space you now
have to scan several ranges of your key
space depending on how you've broken up
your primary key so the other way that
we've mitigated the issues caused by hot
spotting is by using bounded staleness
reads now you might be a little bit sort
of wondering okay I've been talking
about strong consistency through this
whole talk now we're talking about
bounded staleness but you can actually
the nice thing about spanner is that you
can pick and choose when you can
introduce bounded staleness into your
application and where and use it only
where it won't jeopardize the kinds of
high-level semantics that you want to
provide in your application so we don't
use bounded stainless everywhere we use
it where it won't get jeopardize the
semantics that we want to provide to our
user and keep in mind that bounded
staleness reads our
actually much cheaper than strong reads
and that's because typically bounded
staleness reads don't have to go to the
leader oftentimes all of the replicas in
in your spanner database are almost
entirely up to date it's only just that
last small window of transactions that
haven't yet been propagated to all of
the replicas and so even if you just
have a small staleness bound in your
query it will almost always not have to
go to the leader it can go to any
replica and what's nice about spanners
api is that you can easily specify how
much staleness you're willing to
tolerate and spanner will provide a
strong guarantee that that stainless
bound that you provide is is it here to
strictly so here's an example where
we're using bounded staleness reads in
GCS as a performance optimization and
we're not jeopardizing our strong
consistency guarantees by using bounded
staleness reads so what we're doing is
we've got some code in our system that
is attempting to determine whether a
bucket exists and so that's a bucket is
represented by a row in our database so
we first start by issuing a bounded
staleness read for that bucket now
almost all the time that read is going
to return success it's going to say okay
the bucket exists and at that point
you've just issued a bounded stay on
this read and you're done now in the
unusual case it's going to say that
bucket isn't there and in that case we
retry with a strong read to make sure to
differentiate between the case where it
was just the bounded staleness read that
caused that bucket to not be visible
versus the bucket actually not being
present so in an unusual case we'll
retry with a strong read in order to
maintain our strong consistency
guarantees but we still get a big
performance optimization
so to sum up it's been a lot simpler for
Google Cloud Storage to build our
industry-leading functionality
reliability and scale because we've gone
all-in on building our system on top of
spanner and we take advantage of
spanners strong consistency it's simple
programming model it's high availability
and its ability to scale horizontally
[Music]